مدينه كان الحياه تتوقفت فيها هكذات ابن
مدينه باخمود وقد غادرها معظم اهلها
اصوات القصف لا تكاد تتوقف تذكره بان تم
معارك طاحنه تدور على مشارف هذه المدينه
طالت القذائف اجزاء واسعه من بخمون
المنازل والاسواقه ومرافق البنيه التحتيه
ولم تستثني حتى ملعبها الرياضيه الرئيسي
لاحق الدمار بالجسور التي تربط شطرين
المدينه وهو ما يجبر كثيرا من بقي من
سكانها على تجشم عناء رحله يوميه محفوفه
بالمخاطر للحصول على بعض المساعدات
الانسانيه من المؤسسات الاغاثيه التي تجرؤ
على دخول المدينه برشلونه
انها لا تريد ان تتحول الى لاجئه في هذه
السن من حياتها التقينا اندريه وزوجته
الذين خرجا لتفقد شقق من غادر المدينه من
اصدقائهما
ماذا يمكنني ان اقول نعيش وسط اصوات
الانفجارات المرعبه
مدينه بخموت بانها اعنف جبهات القتال في
مقاطعه دونيت الا ان القوات الاوكرانيه ما
زالت تؤكد قدرتها على سد المحاولات
الروسيه المتكرره لاقتحام المدينه من
ثلاثه محاور وقد غدات لا تبعد عنها سوى
نحوي ثلاثه كيلومترات
منذ نحوي اربعه اشهر والقوات الروسيه
تحاول السيطره على مدينه بخمود
الاستراتيجيه لفتح الطريق امامها نحو
سلفيانس وكراماتوس المدينهتين الاهم اللتي
مما تزالان تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
في مقاطعه الدونات